[Music]
now is it true that you have a book of
inspiring quotes coming out is that
right i do it tells you how to rock
climb too
no it tells you how not to rock not
directly what is this book of inspiring
quotes are these your quotes or quotes
that you found in life well some of them
are my own um i that i've posted on
twitter that i've just come up with in
the shower and right i know i wrote a
book and it is actually like a morning
meditation book something that has
helped me throughout the past couple
years just to say inspired and positive
um
which is like 365 quotes with um like a
reading and then a goal for the day and
so yeah i mean i just put 365 quotes
together like i said some of my own but
others like i mean everyone from like
aristotle to tupac
i know like so random but i wanted to
often
aristotle and tupac really often said
the same thing
and you also have a new tour to announce
yes i do
it's called the neon lights tour all
right
uh
i gotta ask you
people are you know and i'm hoping the
obsession dies down and i think it is i
trust the disease is going away but
there's this twerking uh obsession that
people have yes and is there is there
pressure if you're a young performer
these days and you're popular out there
to twerk is there do you ever feel this
pressure like ah that's what people want
i gotta twerk or is
is your manager like get out there and
twerk
come on baby do it
some people look so good doing it and
well i just i just who doesn't look good
doing it exactly
i um
just think i don't really know what it
is i don't understand is it like
twitching and working
is it just dancing like why don't we
just call it dancing anymore i don't
understand dancing is it tweaking and
working like what it what is it exactly
well you're asking the worst person in
the world
i'm the whitest man in america
andy knows more about i think it is
essentially booty shaking
a very particular kind of booty shape
okay but what makes it different yeah
different from any other dance no
booty shaking there's been booty shaking
what's different about this andy i got a
big booty i know how to shake it and i
just i don't know what's the difference
in doing that and twerking
uh i think you'll have to discover that
for yourself
you're right you're right it's not
something that you can't do exactly
that's the word for myself yeah yeah
yeah you got it but he has one of the
quotes in my book as well
that's the quote yeah
do you so you do what you're saying is
you know how to shake your booty do you
shake your booty on stage
just like that
just like that conan why am i doing this
right now because you're in a swirly
chair and it's fine this is me in a
swivel chair that's the most
my booty is always in a swivel chair at
all times that's not true it's true it's
not true i've seen you standing up
before you've seen me standing up you
just stood up to greet me
we all saw it
my perfect plan foiled